today's episode is brought to you by
Ridge wallet now Ridge wallet is
something sometimes it's in your pants
now wallet tree is something you don't
hear a lot about people think a wallet
and they think all just put it in my
pants well that's fine buddy but also
that's not fine the new thing is to have
that Ridge that front pocket carry and
it's a concise piece where you put your
credit cards and the things of value the
real hitters you can keep those in your
Ridge wallet you put it in your front
pocket no more of that back you know
activity where you can get pickpocket or
somebody can just feel your button say
they were trying to touch your wallet
visit Ridge wallet comm slash theö th EO
and use code th EO at checkout for 10%
off
that's code th EO for 10% off at Ridge
wallet comm today's episode I'm joined
by an old friend he and I spent
countless hours barbing each other on
the Opie and Jim Norton podcast on
Sirius XM over about a year and a half
period he's one of the funniest young
man that I know
he's a father he's multi he's a father
of a multiracial child and he's a
beautiful man and he's doing unique
things and I'm so happy to have him here
with me today in studio ladies and
gentlemen mr. Chris de Stefano
[Music]
Wow long time no see what up baby what
up man yeah cuz that's crazy you look
beautiful tonight you got all blue and
you wear blue a lot no I um
not normally i-i've been wearing sweat
pants a lot but you know I'm flying home
today so when I go back to New York you
know can't just you can't come off the
plane in sweats like that really you
know I mean I guess you could but I just
feel like you know I'm going home and
then I gotta go right to see my family
so do you dress nice when you fly do you
dress I got a little penis you know that
I've never seen your penis do what I've
never sent you my dick I never seen that
one that I want to put the I will block
you if you send me it I got one I
thought I sent you one I'm gonna stay up
for I'm 43 days right now um III got one
where you know I send it out as my dick
but it's actually just a television
remote in my sweatpants but it looks
like I have a [ __ ] hog and when girls
ask for a dick pic that's what I send
out and they think like they think I
have the biggest dick ever and then when
we finally do get to sex you know I got
to turn all the lights off and get them
as wet as possible suddenly it's the
it's the Apple TV remotes
yeah do you think it's files yeah I mean
a lot of this firestick what is this
little one sit look out you're not okay
alright because it looks like a I mean
it looks like a hammer really yeah dude
like what kind of you said like a small
hammer it looks like a well it's just
it's just a thick it's a television
remote in grey sweatpants but it looks
like my dick right it's easily put and
I've sent it around sending its women I
sent it well what they asked me I sent
it to women and then and then I sent it
to my boys my boys happened so there's a
circulation that's every that's my crews
dick pic I do not want to be one of your
boys then because I'm trying to do I'm
trying to make it to 44 days and no
pornography I'm not losing my streak cuz
yeah semi now what's the thought process
on that why no porno I don't like it man
it's you it just makes me feel bad about
myself so some of that's my own thing
make me feel bad right but then
secondarily I don't like I don't like
you know honestly just spraying out of
own sink you know it's good
at a certain age when you're young it's
fun cool what's exciting like oh how
much of this in my body yeah but you get
older yeah like I'm still doing this I
still don't have any groceries you know
what yeah it's like listen as you get
older right you only have a finite
amount of energy each day yeah I can't
be using and a lot of that energies in
your boss a lot of a lot of you know
sperm is energy yeah so it's like you
can't like you said be spraying it out
unnecessarily when there's [ __ ] you got
a deal like I'm somebody's dad right so
it's like I can't jerk off into my
bellybutton anymore you know what I mean
that's just [ __ ] I can't do anymore
because I got a kid to feed so it's like
an energy that I have has to be you know
making sure her homeworks done watching
her cartoons get on my career right
going to the gym I can't be on pornhub
you know just just whacking off into my
bellybutton
wow that's I never thought about that
yeah if you're a dad it must feel weird
to jerk off then does it especially
being a dad to a little girl it's like
you know I just when I'm when I'm when I
you know I mean there's still time so
I'm just sitting alone and I flick
around my piece a little bit and just
you know whatever you know if a little
glue comes out a little glue comes out
but it's one of those things where it's
like I'm not actively looking to jerk
off and now I only jerk off like I've
been out in LA for four days in a hotel
room so it's like that's usually that's
usually when you pound your nuts the
most and I haven't jerked off once so
you see not one time man and it hasn't
been like it hasn't been a proactive I'm
not doing this it's just been like I've
been tired you know I'm not you know
I'll FaceTime my daughter and it's like
you know when you're FaceTime in a
three-year-old like that you don't take
off for a couple of days man god you
can't bro yeah you can't I should start
doing that then I should start you'd be
a great father man really I think you
should I think you should do it I really
think you should do it
now what do you know you're out of
wedlock you have a child out of wedlock
I'll die out of wedlock
unfortunately and is that good or bad
for me personally I think it's good and
the kid doesn't like you I've seen her
on Instagram the kid does not like me my
daughter does not like me she doesn't
think I got my special [ __ ] you know cuz
I got it already
yeah and I played a for him for 45
minutes she stared at the TV she just
didn't she didn't laugh once she didn't
even play with her doll she didn't walk
away she just looked emotionless at the
TV I'll post that video when the special
comes out emotionless at the TV for
about 45 minutes and then ask for some
Hamburger Helper yeah
honestly sound like my kind of lady yo
you like no stares blankly at a TV and
then devours a little bit I have no
honest she's like Daddy do to get some
Hamburger Helper definitely a date that
I could do yeah but yeah but I've seen
her on your ice cream for she never
likes you take her to school
I do everything I'm I can't be uh any
more involved of a father than I am and
as a child how old is she she's three
and a half years old Oh
and so she's half Puerto Rican half
Italian yeah so it's and her mom is a
great lady her mom's a great lady I love
and go get wear any matches bro so I can
burn I love I love and support her mom
it just didn't work out with us
romantically but we're very good Co
parents and I think you know when you
ask me for is that I think it's better
to have my child raised around actual
real love and to people that really love
her as opposed to seeing two people who
are like being half shells of themselves
because I don't really love each other
make money say that man I was just text
and I'd been seeing this gal and we and
and we separated and then I was we were
just texting yesterday and it was like
you know maybe sometime we would just
have a child you know do it just like
because I know that she would be a
loving parent like that's the thing I
even made I remember years ago I
remember I made a deal though with the
girl and it was like hey if by 30 yeah
we don't have any kids we're gonna kid
and then I remember like 30 like the
night I turned 30 like 12:01 I get a
text and she's like wow she remembered
and I was like ah you know you know what
I feel like having a child has done for
me big time is it she saves and my
daughter saves me in many ways from like
the the tough things that we go through
in our career like if we don't if we go
out in for an edition and don't get
something or we have a pilot doesn't get
picked up I don't wallow in my sorrows I
don't drink I don't commiserate with my
boys I don't say [ __ ] them [ __ ] that
it's like I that energy I get I'm sad
for a few minutes about it but I got my
daughter saves me in a sense like she
doesn't care like when I had a pilot
with CBS right and it didn't get picked
up and I audition for that pilot I
remember and I didn't get in and he did
well thank God you didn't get in because
now it's in the [ __ ] toilet yeah it's
all les moonves's fault oh yeah didn't
you get busted yeah and it's like you
know what man if you would have picked
up my show you without the protection of
for no family terms in this recent
troubles but now you are on your own
player yeah he's up there yeah so so um
you know when that should happen I
remember I told her she was two at the
time and I was like because I it was
like my whole world came down I was like
I'm sorry you know daddy's thing that he
was doing out there it didn't get picked
up and you know apology apologizing to
her which was silly you know I didn't
but but all she said was you know
Thielen she let me finish she was like
let's watch Mickey Mouse and then so she
was hearing me and you know didn't she's
2 years old so like she has nothing
respond to she was like look basically
what I got from that is like she was
like you're my dad
I don't care what you're doing if you're
here I want to watch Mickey Mouse with
you like that's what's important to me
so don't apologize to me for not getting
a TV show in here like I don't care and
I feel like biologically my daughter
saves me from that and it also helps me
with with conserving my energy like I
don't give energy to stuff that silly
like going back and forth within a text
fight or an Instagram fight or or or
like I said wallowing in my sorrows it's
like I don't I can't man I gotta get my
energy to raise my daughter so
biologically I think a child has saved
me because at first my peers were like
when it all should first happen like
you're dumb man I wouldn't have I
wouldn't have that baby it's gonna it's
gonna and it's all all sudden is
enhanced my career Wow they're all it's
done is enhanced anything that I've
gotten my own a home now you look nice I
used to wear hockey jersey
dude I swear [ __ ] hockey remember we
used to fight on over never seen those
fights on Opie
when he said I look Dutch and then I
told him he looked like Aileen Wuornos
the first female serial killer killer I
was actually I was actually looking at
the comments on the successful seemeth
female serial killers yeah I was looking
at the comments once oh my god dude I
was getting [ __ ] crushed by your fans
yeah well they hated me Oh
oh my god they were like this [ __ ]
bum they would cry bro you literally won
that fighting head that's afraid to go
all the way Rose I'm talking about like
if you look at the first 100 comments
8095 of them like Theo rocks 5 and then
5 then like Chris is good but he still
seems he still sounds deaf you said I
look like a deaf guy that goes to the
gym oh dude usual arias oh you look like
a Def Leppard yeah now everybody else
now Opie and Karl and Chiron are all
dead oh you look like the strongest
deaf person ever dude if you were real
real quiet
yeah and entered a contest for this
person yeah I'm gonna win but here's a
problem you would [ __ ] it up brother you
want to tell a joke and then your hair
and I'm never you didn't have a hat on I
said your hair look like the Michigan
State Spartan helmet and then you told
me that helmet yeah and then you know
you said to me that was so [ __ ] funny
you said you said dude if you if you
could meet yourself you would hate it
there up yeah dude that was epic [ __ ]
that was a dope fight damn I do look
like that [ __ ] no not warrio not only
more you look you fine now son you're
fine girl really girl your whole career
is [ __ ] blown up you got a real
career now man you go out there you sell
tickets
you're not playing bananas in New Jersey
210 people like me
oh they yeah well I'm went over there
and played about the railroad tracks
yeah there was a fire on a train while I
was onstage believe you man happy for
what's it like now when you go to a
place in the tickets are sold it's got
to be a great feeling at this point
right yeah I guess it I mean it
definitely is it is different you know
it's funny it's like you can't you
almost forget what it was like when it
wasn't interesting and you felt and you
just almost forget about it quick and
you also get nervous that like you know
I feel more pressure now to make jokes
right whereas before I just felt a
pressure to be myself right but now it's
like they want to be funny they paid
good money to see you right and now I
feel a little bit of that all the time
as some of it I don't like and some hope
I'm trying to find ways in my own like
to get back into a place where I just
feel like that pressure isn't there well
you won't even in like a day even in
like a day-to-day basis you know like I
mean Nick's done so much to help our
podcast grow and like Instagram and
write you know he really championed a
lot of different ideas and you know so
it's been everything you guys got is
professionalist one of the cameras you
know the content it's all like it's like
podcasting is a business now it's almost
like for our friends who don't have
podcasts like and who still think like
doing a late-night set matters it's like
you're the best [ __ ] is so 20 you're out
of your pan it's 20 19 yeah the only way
to get ahead is to
like you know having somebody out here
like like a joe rogan like you know all
you guys you know get like that's like
being on The Tonight Show like you guys
so like you know Johnny Carson was like
the guy and then like all the comedians
we've ever heard of Seinfeld Ray Romano
all these guys who blew up and became
icons did so through Carson and now I
feel like it's Joe Rogan it's like now
you got you know you Bert Kreischer Tom
Segura all these guys are there selling
more tickets than anybody what's the
common theme you know you guys all you
know crushed it when you came on Rogan
you're all crushed it and then cuz
there's one thing it's like people
comedians could go on big podcasts and
not do well and then nothing happens so
it's like one of those things you guys
were all you guys were all great and
then you guys all went on the episodes
and crush so it's like now his fans
become your fans but now it's not even
now it's your fans so now it's like when
you go yeah maybe the first time they
heard of you was through this guy or
through that everybody needs a godfather
yeah you know but now it's like yeah
you've converted real fans and I think
the only way that we can do that now in
2019 is through podcasting so when I
came out here to promote my special I
was like man I want to do Bert and I
want to do Theo I would love to have
done Rogan and but it's not possible
right now I get I gotta get to the next
level but but I was like that's more
important to me than doing any
late-night [ __ ] like the late-night book
is like oh you know cuz it's so PC now
they're like oh I had jokes about my
daughter yeah Puerto Rican and you know
and they were all my Comedy Central
special because one thing I'll say about
Comedy Central is they're about the
comedian first that's why it's dope
that's why I like specials that come out
on Comedy Central
our dope because they they that the
executives they are not scared they're
like you know this is the name Comedy is
in our network right now if you think
that shit's funny even if it's crossing
the line and whatever then we'll stand
by you and protect you so don't summon
Ron Funches clips and his just did
really well and I usually just clips huh
yeah where he called his son the n-word
yeah yeah man and I respected it was
just like that's hot it was so funny
yeah dude but for them to be willing to
also put that down and I just saw one of
yours too much they start putting clips
here there's no clips of mine up now
yeah someone yes so I have a clip
actually one of the clips I put up is me
impersonating my poor my daughter can we
play it or not yeah sure I don't care
what we get in trouble for playing that
name mm-hmm well it's where is it posted
it's on my Instagram okay yeah fine in
his daughter's Puerto Rican yeah my
Puerto Rico
actually this the the clip that I was on
my answer I'm I'm gonna post a darker
one tomorrow the clip that's on my bill
that crib you know what I'm saying okay
yeah baby they they they they said I
couldn't do it on late night when I
could do those jokes but I couldn't
impersonate and put on a Puerto Rican
accent cuz I'm not Puerto Rican and
inside my that's such [ __ ] like it's
my daughter
yeah you know what I mean it's my kid
it's your kid and you know what's funny
is they'll let anybody get on there and
impersonate like somebody from the South
or some Midwest yeah or somebody who
they think is you know uneducated as
long as the only educated person isn't
black yes it's but if it's like they're
white in on it yeah then it's fine but
the thing is the people there in all
these networks they're [ __ ] white
yeah but that's why I like what you have
like the six the type of success you
have and the the way that you're selling
tickets now is so powerful because you
could not that you're scandalous dude
unless you still finger women do you
still get paid to finger women well
that's not anymore
okay so you sure you're not scandalous
dude and it's like even if even if you
said something that was out of bounds
unintentionally your fans are still
gonna be there man you're still gonna go
to wherever a place and sell out that
theater where some of these dudes are
comedian friends who are tied up with
these on these networks like they say
one [ __ ] their [ __ ] careers done you
know everything will be taken away from
them but you got real fans that [ __ ]
with you right I could say whatever you
want to them because they're like and
that's what I want that's what you guys
have out he and that's what I'm going
after like I got a podcast called the
history hyenas yeah it's you and
Gianna's man Yanis papasan we go [ __ ]
wild in that podcast and he's uh where's
he from he's Greek isn't he's Greek yeah
we go wild and our fans you know they're
not as powerful and big as your guys fan
base is yet but it's like you know we're
trying to get there man we just with its
unfiltered [ __ ] we're talking about
history but we're being honest about
[ __ ] you know you know it's dumb
certainly deserve a man you and Andrew
Schultz are too like the funniest guys
that always think about what schultzy is
his Schultz he's got a career that's
that like you man Schultz Schultz
whoever he goes he sells out and he put
his [ __ ] on every Network cenotes
shelter everybody everybody's to notice
our special every single was a like a
male sure I heard all kinds whatever
[ __ ] they said but he was the the
best comedian I saw when I was in new
yeah now he's got millions and millions
and millions of views and what does that
translate to ticket sales yeah so it's
like you know you gotta have this
mindset where it's like the fit we got
the fans give us power like we and we up
the fan
direct access to us and we have direct
access to them it wasn't like that in
the 90s it's like you know I mean like
Jerry's Jerry Seinfeld can only be
Seinfeld with one show on NBC you know I
and there was only one big show there
was a few networks it's like now with
this oversaturation it's like man you
like some you can walk you could be set
you could walk past the theater that you
have sold out and people may not even
recognize you because they're sold out
with your specific fans whereas like
back in the day it's like to be like a
big you know if a guy who was selling
out theater tickets he would not be able
to get through the airport without
having to take a thousand autographs
right but shit's different now like John
Wayne yeah man it's like who else jumped
[ __ ] Marilyn Monroe no Kareem
abdul-jabbar Kareem I'm trying to
entertainer though maybe new John Newton
that's something you know John Newton
let's play the clip real quick I [ __ ]
not Olivia Newton I hey myself out my
baby mama is it you need to have the
answers whip you need to like have facts
right away because they won't arrogate
you and if you don't have the answers
quick you look like a liar and they
watch men they are designed to watch men
watching waiting that's what they do
they make excellent NFL referees I think
if you had Porto Rican girls roughing
the games you'd have zero missed calls
the whole season because they see
everything
that's just what then could you imagine
they were the reps they would be right
there like um yeah to bounce the bet
I mean yes you are about awesome yeah I
don't need instant replay I saw you I
don't even know the rules just go home
yeah they told me I can't do that [ __ ]
on late-night cuz I'm impersonating
Puerto Ricans how wild is that we live
in a [ __ ] Twilight Zone kind of world
man
but it's eating itself like that they're
all that stuff it's like dude I remember
four years you know they said well you
can't do comedy because you were on a
reality television all right and then
they said well you you know then they'll
say oh well you know we don't we don't
need a southern guy we don't need this
and like and there was even no
opportunities there's no shows even and
I'm not even a something I must from the
south but yeah I don't like you're not
like a Larry the Cable guy's southern
comedian yeah I don't identify with I
mean identified this with like I mean if
anything identify with somebody who
doesn't feel like they are valued right
and that could be anyone
that could be anyone there you go yes
yeah and yeah and I feel like my comedy
is for anyone who you know is it's kind
of like misinterpreted where like you
would look at me and think I'm gonna
talk about you know whatever football
and sports and banging chicks but I'm
really just talking about anxiety
hanging chicks and they tell let's be
honest banging dude yeah shout out
Grindr man some chick yeah now I've had
a chick or two yeah I don't that's
another thing man here's here's what I
learned about myself I'm the kind of
dude I fall in love with men but I have
sex with women yeah I common like I
could fall in love that you dude but we
go to the beach we could chill like I
could do this all day
I'm not trying to have sex with you but
I wanna have sex with a woman like
you'll get me horny and I'll bang out a
chick I like is it that wild yeah it's a
wild [ __ ] kind of brain to have right
like tell your friend hey amber come
over bring up Keith over for a little
bit too but ya know yeah he can want to
talk to me about about football and
stuff and about like what he feels about
[ __ ] but then I want to get in your
[ __ ] yeah yeah but I don't want to talk
to you that's [ __ ] wild that's quiet
man yeah it is interesting man it's uh
you know it's it's a good hair bro
I do yeah dude I just [ __ ] wish I
could grow my [ __ ] out like that
I can't though for you I wonder how you
would look with longhand yeah I would
[ __ ] you have it then you have a
ponytail somebody said I never brought
you used to work on like on one of those
like um like daytime cruise boat yeah do
you know we should do mean you we should
do a like a boxing match for charity and
the winner has to get the other guy's
haircut never do a charity it's a great
with it they always said Yogi's gonna be
now dude I feel like you could catch me
man that's me on the chin once I'd be
done dude if I I can't no I couldn't do
it man um but it's so interesting the
stuff that you're saying just about like
like the industry and like people doing
their own thing I remember after I went
on Joe Rogan when I went on Joe Rogan's
podcast and I left out of there and I
was like man he he has his own thing
right now right yeah and it really
inspired me I was like oh wow I could do
I could do my own thing I mean dude look
look look at all like the big interviews
of the last year you know like the big
gets Elon Musk
you know Barack Kanye West is like
people can't wait nice and today my ties
today that [ __ ] used to be Barbara
Walters man that was Barbara Walters
2020 that's how the country tuned in to
that now you go to Joe Rogan yeah so
it's like one of those things where you
know to have a dude like that as like as
like a gatekeeper is a squad just wish I
knew if I lived out here I hope I'll get
to know him better but that's the only
that's the only issue still holding New
York back is a lot of the dudes that are
really popping off you know with
podcasts and you guys are out here we
have guys in New York like Ari Shaffir
on them and it's awesome to do their
shows yeah but like popping off popping
off like you guys it's not we don't have
that really yet in New York yeah I mean
I feel pretty fortunate yeah like even
though I said I get to hang around some
of those guys like there's somebody sent
us this picture that a man made yes
though yeah I mean I was so nervous when
Tong Joe Rogan's I was so nervous and
even this time I was still a little bit
nervous it's like because you almost
feel like it is the Tonight Show in some
ways he'll honor man but then it's also
like trying to get to know him and like
yeah the most time we ever spend
together is on there when we've been
time together at the Comedy Store but
it's not like
right you're sitting down really being
able to communicate one let's see and
see that's what I like about you know
podcast his podcast and all you guys
podcast and every podcasting is like if
you gain fans if I can step out of here
like say today if I step out here and
I've gained some of your fans
I didn't fool them because it would be
talking for an hour like a late-night
set a five minute thing you can fool
somebody like see they're five minutes
at the comedy sort of like all that dude
ripped and then you go watch outside
suck if you're listening to me for over
an hour and you're in then you're in
inkling in this I can't I can't fool you
man funny by after now you're like I
don't [ __ ] with this dude then you're
never gonna [ __ ] me and that's okay
too but that's why I'm saying like
that's what I mentioned before it's like
you could go on these big guys podcasts
and a lot of comedians just come and go
on them but to be able to stick and get
their fans that means like you really
move them and then now they're your fans
you know I mean and that's what I want
with my career I just want like it's
gonna happen it I want it's happening
well no I want one of those I want to be
one of those guys though like my people
always ask me like oh what's your goals
and [ __ ] like Michael not what number
one to sell tickets and number two I
know it's subjective and it's like
people say I don't care what people
think and that's true to a degree but I
think it is important to have respect
from your peers
I want my peers in comedy be like hey
Chris would be funny in any decade he's
not just funny because of the parameters
of 2019 right he's not just funny cuz
he's saying some politically correct
charge interesting message that is
getting claps that yes he's getting you
know accolades for now but it's really
only getting accolades because times
have changed I want to be like yo that
do would have been funny in 1979 and
he's funny in 2019 and there's really no
objective way to measure that that would
just be subjectively through my peers
being like oh you know that that's how
we feel about you so that's that's what
my goal is you feel like most comedians
feel like you're very funny though
there's no doubt about that I think I
think you know what it is man I think
once I started to get in New York like
the oh geez out here like you guys you
know like you know you got the Joe
Rogan's and and and you know Marc Maron
and and guys have been out here for a
long time like our OGS are like Colin
Quinn Dave Attell ya Bobby Kelly they do
these like the oh geez at the Comedy
Cellar so those guys are you know I get
invited to those guys barbecues and I
work with those guys and they invite me
to shows like like Colin Quinn is like a
personal friend of mine so that's more
that's more validation for me than any
late-night should I ever did any TV show
ever did it's like the validation comes
from the peer it's like
Alan Quinn saying hey I put my stamp on
this guy then that's good enough no I
mean yeah man I mean you're I feel like
it's just such a great story were you
bummed that the how did that feel
obvious you were bummed oh and you said
that the daughter kind of changed it for
you but did you feel like was there a
moment when the the pilot that you had
you didn't go you were like I was [ __ ]
up man I mean you know I it happened I
was in San Francisco and they told me
and the flight was taking off like
literally where you know you know like
when you turn on your phone on airplane
mode that last second as the plane start
to accelerate that's what I was doing
and it was like my thumb was like
halfway to that airplane mode and the
text you know came in on the top of the
screen for my manager CBS pass sorry bud
and that's you know what I mean and then
so is just like airplane mode hit it and
it was just like I got you know I listen
I I licked my wounds I said you know
what for five hours while I'm in these
guys I'm gonna have a few drinks I'm
gonna [ __ ] let loose I'm gonna be
upset I'm gonna going on there anybody
cool on the plane and I was just it was
just me and [ __ ] might even remember
that now I don't even remember I was
business class so I got that I got to
upgrade to business class luckily right
before so there was some goodwill right
in it so so I remember I just cried a
little bit I just cried a little bit in
the bathroom you really shed it here and
absolutely yet because my new foot don't
forget for that when they told me man
buddy are there was 18 months of my life
that was on hold you know 18 months of
my career where it's like and and and
you know they they do a good job these
networks of making you feel like you're
the man and trust me man you're right
here when the reality was you know my
[ __ ] and the see here so here's here's
why it hurt a little bit more as one of
those things where it's like if I'm
playing a sport like when I was when I
was playing basketball I would rather
lose by a hundred then lose by one at
the buzzer and overtime cuz it's like
the heart at least 100 you could be like
all right it ain't gonna happen
yeah so when they released that Friday
in in May when they released oh you know
CBS has green let these four shows you
know we call my reps called CBS and they
were like you know thank you for the
opportunity you know we just saw the
dead lion article we didn't make any
said note that CBS like no no no they're
gonna pick up a fifth show it's between
your show and another show so he's not
out yet we're negotiating right now les
Moonves and the powers that be at CBS
are all talking about and it took two
hours but they picked the other show so
so is the other show the other show was
um wasn't that mad
come in the middle well no no the other
show was was living biblically it got
canceled after three episodes the show
was sued and living Billy is hard bro
yeah are you trying to do it right now
for three days in a row yeah you know
yeah you gotta hide your favorite friend
behind a rock you no matter what the
temperatures you gotta we'll go out
there and sandals got cancelled
immediately don't [ __ ] know man that
[ __ ] got cancelled immediately Jamie
Kennedy was that you could have lost out
to gravity hunters living biblically
[ __ ] hurt man did you watch the thing
honestly watch it really with an open
mind like a true open mind and that was
like you is it just means this [ __ ] suck
dick they're like my boys were like you
know this is the worst TV show I've ever
[ __ ] seen and then I waited the next
day to like you know like they released
like you know they put it out there at
least of ratings and you know like all
variety calm down you know their first
episode of the TV show that you know
they were [ __ ] hating on they were
like who greens someone somebody
someone's in prayer a variety yeah likes
it said CBS takes a dump on Monday
nights with new who pick up of living
biblically that's one of the headlines
was that was like [ __ ] living biblically
in a sit back title to but I guess they
feel like middle America you know they
live look like I will live and that's
another problem with Hollywood man I've
said this the people that work in
Hollywood a third fourth fifth
generation right you know and it's a
probably Jewish but it's a Jew business
like you know and so it's like they
don't have that much of a connection to
yeah well they used to some used to be
people that had moved you know people
that had moved to Los Angeles from New
York from other parts of America right
but now it's just third for generations
so yeah a lot of these people don't even
know anyone right they've never been to
visit a family member in different part
know so they have no way so of course is
show like living biblically yeah to some
mutant that has no I know what a half of
America is like and it's like like oh
that sounds good like Los Angeles too
and many parts of New York now they feel
like little islands off the coast of
real America like you said it's so
disconnected allow they really do it's
like little islands or if the cuz the
actual real America doesn't you know the
actual real America doesn't give a [ __ ]
if there's a transgender Asian lead in a
pilot they just want to be funny if the
transgender Asian lead is funny they're
gonna [ __ ] with your show but they don't
give a [ __ ] so these people sit in these
towers and you know first of all some of
the people making decisions on my CBS
show we're in the accounting department
three years ago now not saying that to
be funny I'm talking about there was a
dude who was giving me notes on my
comedy who's in the accounting
department of CBS three years prior and
just somehow moved up so it was like so
the one thing that I took away from it
though the lesson that I have cuz I
really did learn [ __ ] you know there
says yeah I feel like there's you only
learn through pain right that that's
really what I believe so so when I went
through that pain man you know it hurt
and then but what I learned was this I
realized looking back in hindsight so
many times I overrode my own gut I
overrode my gut in the sense that I
would let a CBS person tell me hey it
would be funnier if you did this and it
would be funny if you do that and your
comedy should be about this and I listen
to them because I said you know what I'm
gonna listen to them and then I'm gonna
get my pilot on the air because it's
exactly what they want and then my and
then I can and then I cannot do it I
walk out myself and they the worst feel
in the world was not only having my
pilot not picked up but looking at it
and even though I was proud of it
because the guys are created with who
created her Matt your mother were great
dudes but when when when I looked and I
said you know what this was there this
was it turned into their comedy Wow and
I was like I'll never do that again like
right now I got a cartoon and
development with with Comedy Central
write about my life and it's like I'm
good I can work with teams I'll listen
I'll listen I'll take a joke from
somebody off the street cuz you never
know gold is gold it's out there but if
my gut is telling me no this is not
funny or no this is not gonna work then
I'm not gonna override it anymore I'm
gonna say nope this is what I want cuz I
want to at least live and die with my
decisions not somebody else's decisions
that I made because I thought it would
help my career and it didn't and I
learned that I learned that the hard way
but DITA now is because I hear this a
lot cuz we doing a pilot right now with
Comedy Central called man up and it's
based on life
people call down to the podcast notes
unscripted Oh so we had three digital
episodes and they're online and a lot of
our fans know our a lot of our you know
the crew that listens know about them
but it's like you people call them to
the podcast and then we get meet up in
person and try to help them with some
sort of situation that's going on in
their life and maybe not help but just
be part of their life stuff you know so
but yeah there's some ideas from like oh
I know this would be super funny Brian
I've gotten other ideas from the network
they're like well why don't we do this
sometimes I'm like and then the
producers will be like well if you do
what they are saying right then they cuz
there's gonna be some of the ones that
are gonna make the decision that ain't
true though because the truth is the
truth is well first thing I'll say this
and I mean this I'm not just saying this
cuz I have a special on them and I have
a overall deal with them I truly from my
heart the cop the executives I've worked
with at least in New York on Comedy
Central and I know some LA dudes and
they're all I put them in the same vein
they are about funny first and they at
least are very experienced in their job
like you're not like almost all the
executives at Comedy Central come from a
comedy background they weren't in the
accounting department two years ago yeah
so they know comedy but still if it's
gut for you feels wrong then you have to
override them but I know more than any
other executive ever work with Comedy
Central knows what they're doing but you
know I feel like I feel like yeah so
like if but but if it feels wrong to you
then yeah I mean there's nothing there's
nothing you could do about it because
they tell you they're like oh well
you're gonna have you know you're gonna
have if you do this then if they like
you know you kind of want to appease
them some because I don't want to get
what they want you don't want to give
them something that seems so foreign to
them well you know what's another thing
too it's like you know what do you think
there's some truth to that
I do because I think when your producer
said to you oh give like you know I'll
do what they say cuz these are gonna be
the people making decisions the truth of
the matter is even with the most even
with the most seasoned comedy executives
and this is I'm sure it's true and drama
and all that too but I can only speak
the comedy count executives they don't
know what they want they don't know they
only know what they want when you show
them so they could say oh how about this
you know what Theo I think I think you
should have that plan over here and that
would be funny but if you just say you
go rogue and you say you know what I'm
putting the [ __ ] plant where I wanna
put the plan
was certainly like that's genius and
then they pick up your [ __ ] because a
lot of times they're going in blind they
don't know they have no idea what they
want until you show it to them you know
when I learned that when I was casting
my pilot where I was like cuz I was on
the other side of the camera
CBI so I was i I watched hundreds of
audition tapes hundreds and dealt with
hundreds of people coming in and out and
everybody that pretty much came in you
know to be honest with you there was
three there was three of the parts I
wanted somebody else because I was like
when they came in I was like no this is
the person this has got to be the person
but they overrode me because they wanted
big celebrities and and and I get it I
get it's a business tool I get
everything can't be about the art I get
my show business i but stacking things
with celebrities is so limiting these
days I feel like it's like it's just
like even with the election it's like
you know they just they're like you know
Hollywood controls so much and so all
the celebrities are like we're gonna
we're gonna get on the same thing but
listen man right and it didn't work cuz
most of America knows it's fake me yeah
I'm telling you man we just know we
could it's very easy to see the [ __ ]
like it's very very easy to see when
you're know where you're in an award
show when you're watching award show the
Oscars are cold and goes whatever and
these celebrities just going up there
patting themselves on the back and just
being windbag man it's so inferior
because you know it's fake because you
know when they go home they're probably
using plastic straws and they don't give
a [ __ ] about the turtles yeah no I mean
oh well 10 years ago it was like gas and
fishing cars and now does that that's
not even a thing that's not trendy
anymore like it never shows up to
Priuses and all yeah man it's G it makes
me mad it's just whack and I think most
most of the country sees the [ __ ]
most of us do I mean you know but I've
been punched in the face a lot you've
been punched in the face lot like I live
my life in the gray zone because you
know it is it's like somebody on Twitter
you know that wants to stand by his or
her opinions it's like yeah you could
stand by your opinions and start
blocking people but the truth is this
[ __ ] hasn't gotten violent for you right
as I would like if you're a real [ __ ]
martyr then say what you just said to
the Appa to a person to to somebody who
doesn't agree with you to their face and
then see what see if you really stand by
your opinion yeah I've been hit so much
that I [ __ ] you know I know man it's
like you listen man I got I got opinions
but I'm not standing by anything like
you know what I mean
once you put those fists up if you want
me to change my tune its who will be
changed
yeah man I mean it's definitely it
definitely is like the Wild West
I mean I feel so great fathering you
know how I happened into like you know I
mean I know I did a lot of work over the
years doing stand-up but you did your
thing man you just you know and now and
now look and it's a beautiful thing
because now it's like you have an
opportunity to like be out here for like
long format stuff
people get to know you that feel like
they're a part of your family yeah and
then they come out to the shows man and
you'll never lose them you'll never lose
the fans you tell people like you on
that I think are fun dude you could do
something [ __ ] up tomorrow and maybe
you lose ads on the podcast yeah but you
ain't gonna you ain't gonna lose your
fans what do you think I would do that
we [ __ ] up an honest crime you could
see me doing the medic the head honest
real [ __ ] that I could see you doing a
real crime and I'm gonna tell you a
couple about you yeah okay so like a guy
like you well first of all you look like
you're on crystal meth like you know
what I mean like I know you're not but
like you look like like like it would be
it would be shocking to me that a guy
that looks like you isn't using crystal
meth like I'd be it I'm in shock that
you're not why cuz there's not a t-shirt
under the sweater what this is just a
sweater to scan the sweater to skin yeah
and really like and just like the hair
and the beard it's like it's like you
just look like on a beard
well whatever like a hairy it's got like
a civil war head you know what I mean
and it just looks like like you use
drugs to like get through your pain you
know I mean so I would think so I so
definitely like robbing a liquor store
is what you look you have that robbing a
liquor store look you also look like you
could be like you're you a suspect
you look I dress in any making a
murderous [ __ ] like you're on the list
for sure you're on the short list so I
would say one of those either a murder
suspect or robbing a bank but I think
like actual crime you could actually do
like with who you are as CEO not on
drugs like la like as Theo von right now
so I think you I could see you being to
being a distracted driver texting and
kill a mentally-challenged that's you
doing and then leaving the scene of the
accident
oh yeah I could see you doing that and
then you out leave with him don't put
them back yeah car yeah and as a temp to
cover yeah like and then raise them at
home exactly but you could lose a
sponsor for that yeah yeah you may lose
an ad but what about years later when I
reintroduce him to society and he don't
[ __ ] dance yeah I mean it's like that
movie now man that movie me
and that song at the end if I asked you
to find any wheel and I'm out of know a
gymnasium yeah do his parents haven't
seen him for years and they're not even
excited to see ya
and I'm out there dude he gets up and
just would you see MA so tonight me and
then he'd just pirouettes here and it's
at that beautiful that's the crime I
could see two gay guys in the stands is
hold a lighter up yeah it's like chill
out fellas you know yeah this boy's mine
what about me what do you think I could
do let me think I could see you being
like obviously you seem like a dude that
works at a tollbooth that's [ __ ] all
right I tells people is gonna do
something different like on your lunch
break eat all the black ladies you're
gonna be doing something different just
don't keep coming back yeah you always
pocket a couple of quarters you think
you have a scheme it's like stealing
like 75 cents a day yes stacking it up
at home for like a big adventure yeah my
mother for sure City yeah so petty crime
like that 75 cents it didn't rhyme I
could see you doing yeah um what else I
could see you uh going into the Air
Force I could see you doing some like a
wall type of [ __ ] right yeah yeah like
going rogue going to another country
yeah Afghanistan or Saddam doing some
[ __ ] like that saying yeah or somewhere
Iraq and just like because like because
I just want to defend freedom and defend
my country I'm killing innocent women
and children yes some dirty homeland
type yeah yeah
next thing you're over there in a
[ __ ] sweat lodge yeah just drinking
curry through us yeah Isis gets me the
try I got but I got such a big head I
just keep [ __ ] up there beheading
videos yeah I got like a size 8 had hair
I could see you yeah and getting in a
lawsuit with New Era hats they don't
have a proper fit yeah I got a big-ass
head man your duds are yeah yeah no I'm
not Dutch actually I thought my whole
life I was Italian and German like every
other you know white piece of [ __ ] on
the East Coast but I found that I'm like
70% German Wow yeah mostly German so you
were kind of right a little while yeah
that's all right
yeah what are some what's the Louie CK
situation like in New York is it
different than it is out here well I
don't know I mean he doesn't really come
you don't really he doesn't pop up out
here right no I heard why yeah what
there was one night where I heard that
he was at like the lyric theater or
something and this was about six weeks
ago but that's I I just heard it from
one person and so I don't know if that's
true yeah he pops up you know
comedy selling shows like that and it's
just like you know it's one of those
things I think the main difference that
I see now is he doesn't really hang out
he just come does his spot and leaves
does he seem nervous um you know and
just vibe you know just by uh I would
say the first night I was there the
first time he came back he was nervous
for sure I think even he would admit
that yeah how could you not be yeah um
but now not so much
I mean he's you know burying his notes
kind of writing thing comes out you know
he's got to deal with every time he goes
up people will walk out and leave you
know he's gonna have to probably deal
with that for as much as he comes in
unannounced to a comedy club he's gonna
have to deal with people being like we
want our money back it's just you know
it's just what it is in society right
now but uh every to be honest with you
man every time he goes up he murders he
rips like the people there they they
because it's like it's good jokes it's
like it's like look you know Bill
Cosby's in prison because what he did
was a crime and he doesn't deserve a
chancellor and maybe he would after he's
rehabilitation in prison that's what
these laws are it's what we have laws
then yeah hypothetically he should be
allowed to come back because he did his
time louis c.k never committed a crime
right for sure what he did was outside
the fringes of what's normally socially
accepted he can do jerking off on a plan
is hella hella vegan yeah yeah you
putting that net yeah and look at his
energy into n Utley that's a soup out
here [ __ ] it man
I need that in North Hollywood I'd have
a little I'm not gonna have a lot yeah
but it's like you know what the [ __ ] of
course it was you know uh you know right
the media definitely got a hold of him
he definitely got his little to lose his
life in this career no power yeah anyway
whenever I saw me see Mikey we had a
real hard ego like just like he was also
the biggest comedian like yeah like real
comedian yeah man what it is to be at
the top like that everybody asking you
for [ __ ] one shift from you so look man
I don't know Louie - well the few times
I have been around him he's been kind to
me you know he really has been and um
but you know I know like the situations
that he put some people in it wasn't
right but it's not a crime and he
doesn't loot the deserve to lose his
career over it yeah I don't think so man
I think if you commit a crime then yeah
you like Cosby is what happened to Cosby
is right Harvey Weinstein these guys if
shit's proven you should go to jail for
that yeah he got caught up in there you
know he definitely was in that tidal
wave of stuff that was
at the same time yeah man so it's like
but look rules have changed I think the
positive things about all these
movements is I know at some you know
there's people that take advantage of
them and then the media wants to jump on
that too and people want to jump on that
but look things have changed man I'll
tell you what I've always respected
women you know I was I grew up around
all women but like I certainly made me
think about my actions exactly it's like
maybe thinking like you know what the
way I was in 2010 I still wasn't not
raping anybody or assaulting anyone but
I maybe wasn't as self-aware as I am now
you know that's positive I think that's
ultimately what they wanted yeah well
there's definitely some positives yeah
there's always but you know there's
always gonna be people cuz it's like you
know people walk around in fear themself
guys say I can't do anything that's like
well you can't be an [ __ ] well if ya
know what I mean like if if some girl
comes accusing me [ __ ] it's like it's
not gonna be true well they don't do any
it made me think about my sit one like
it made me think about like it made me
think about a couple things made me
think like wow it did make me look at
myself yeah you know a couple things
even some of these movements like I'm in
the black lives matter stuff what's
happening was real you know big more
popular right um you know if that was a
time like when truly you know the Trump
was running for president and he was
like really divided and that's it that's
the time when I felt like dude there's
nobody even in like I came all the way
to LA to be you know I felt like I would
grew up really a Democrat you know I
grew up or a Democrat opportunities you
know I grew up you know never like the
rich really because they the one thing I
didn't like about the rich was that if
one of them got in trouble for something
they were able to get out of it right
before it never got to the papers the
next day it never in the middle of the
night there was some phone calls emails
and they were able to get through
somebody new somebody and that's the
thing that always because then there was
no consequence right for them right and
so that always just made me so angry
right but anyways but then I get out to
LA and then I'm suddenly I'm like you
know looked at as like um you know
everybody just immediately is like oh
well this guy was just a redneck this
guy's an idiot right you know just cuz
the way that I sound or just was like yo
judged ya cuz of my skin and it made me
and I couldn't I was like I there's not
even any roles for me here you know like
whenever they even champion to Southern
comedian in some sense when Larry the
Cable had that that Fox is 25 but that's
what I'm saying that's why I think what
you did is so great
you just built your own way yeah and
that's thank God we have the opportunity
to do that in 2019 because if this was
1999 you would be [ __ ] right you know
you're not but now it made me think but
in 99 I think you still have some
opportunities they had like [ __ ] like
the torkoal sons and [ __ ] yeah some
other show guys living biblically yeah
always but some dumb decisions I'm
saying that publicly CBS oh dude yo
should have kept you boy
these people look I can't even imagine
the number of bad shows that have been
passed around these troubled rooms yeah
I could have been on the dank torkelson
I would have definitely that made that
up yeah yeah kid with the blue pack I
was a group of people I thought it was
like a cartoon of like seahorses what
station was it on oh I don't know ABC
NBC you know we had two stations on one
of them yeah but I remember this so this
is what I remember I remember being like
man because how I sound or how I looked
and I'm not gonna have it I'm not kind
of any opportunities right I really
feeling that and then I was like man
this must be how you know like people
feel sometimes probably or this must be
how yeah Latinos never complain really
no Latinos are gonna OPA take over the
world
yeah and I would happily say bienvenidos
because now that's why I deserve it
that's why I have a Puerto Rican
daughter man I'm [ __ ] gotten that [ __ ]
early man I get it for my career 100%
cuz you know I'm a straight white male
we're very easily hateable and I look
like a tiki torch you know what I mean I
look like the problem I'm undercover cop
so my Puerto Rican daughter man it's
like what are you gonna say to me now
I'm like [ __ ] I got my baby Puerto
Rican girl yeah you know you look like
definitely like a guy that works at the
church it gets busted like a church
pastor but the shady yeah you know I
look like somebody's ex yeah I look like
I look like somebody's ex huh you look
like definitely every ex-husband in a
lifetime but yeah like you you know you
dating this girl your lover and then
she's like oh I have a kid with this guy
you're in and it's a [ __ ] letdown
you're like [ __ ] I got a dude this guy's
gotta be a part of my life yeah you
should carry a launch pad like I'm
coming up with some like [ __ ] protein
infused vodka since you like it it's a
dumbass invention but it made me feel
like that it brought that it brought it
at the I mean it brought in to my mind
and it brought in my heart I was like
man this is how yeah somebody must feel
if they don't feel like they have an
opportunity right and so that was I
never would have had that
yeah and now that's a macro level at a
micro level yeah some people don't take
advantage of their opportunities you
know some you know people have a million
opportunity no matter what color their
skin are and they don't they never
really and like I'm and like when you
just put the product out there when it's
unfiltered uncensored it's like just
coming from my brain like as the artist
like I'm sure you find like like my fan
base at the History hyena podcast it's
very it's so culturally diverse like
it's so culturally diverse it's crazy
men women all different races religions
and I'm sure you feel the same because
funny it's funny man but these
executives and these people in these
so-called gatekeepers and bloggers want
to say oh you have to talk about this
group or do that it's like yo bro funny
is funny has no race it's it's a
universal language it's like that's what
brings [ __ ] together like my pops
old-school Italian guy right like
nowadays in in 2019
you could blog about him and you could
make my father a villain when in reality
my dad in 2012 when Hurricane sandy
happened and it like ravaged New York
Staten Island where my pops lives the
coasts of Staten Island got [ __ ] up
and most of it is like most of it was
Latino immigrants and and and black
people most of it but my dad's house was
not touched so my dad went to the u-haul
truck every single day went down there
helped out the families and even for two
weeks let two separate families stay in
his house while they because they had
nowhere else to go but so you know while
he was doing that my dad's just an
old-school kind of guy comes from a
different world he was making jokes like
they got one guy's name was Jose he kept
calling him Juan he kept telling him
like hey don't steal my silverware you
know like you guys want to play bait
like just she corny old hackneyed a
jokes but the truth is is like all those
families they love him like he's their
dad because he saved their lives for two
weeks right so it's like everybody wants
to I feel like I feel like Isis ayat II
we're in defense mode it's like somebody
gets famous oh now we're waiting for
that person to [ __ ] up dig through their
tweets what's gonna go wrong like with
Kevin Hart yeah oh go back ten years to
find tweets like well if you really
wanted if actions spoke if actions truly
spoke louder than words is that [ __ ]
that they regurgitate that to be honest
mostly the left regurgitates
yeah but the actions speak louder than
words then you would see Kevin Hart's
actions in ten years finding no tweets
but all of a sudden to make the
narrative good for you you're gonna flip
it and say oh now were
birds are louder than actions so it's
like what you know you playing an
unwinnable game that's why you're having
a podcast and having your own fan base
is my goal because my P I can speak to
my people I'm immune talk like you're
immune to all that [ __ ] man
you've got nobody's digging through your
tweets and if they are that they're your
fans right I mean yeah and it's like
also like I don't understand how you
don't like expect that like how can you
be like everybody deserves the
opportunity to change but then you know
you're preaching that all the time but
then you're not there's no empathy for
people there's no like well what if
somebody does change you know like how
can somebody not change like you should
be great you saw something 10 years ago
you don't have anything now yeah it's
like you know even like you know those
you know the cha charlottesville when
they have the tiki torches or whatever
you know and but 50 that you know 60
years ago or something or 40 years ago
they had in the 60s they had like a Klan
rally I think that had 50,000 people in
Madison Square Garden yeah man like what
a great progress I can't her that's
[ __ ] up but it's like why not be like
oh the last-ditch effort of so mania in
1938 the Nazis sold out Madison Square
Garden my peoples they sold out they
sold out MSG how many shows do they do I
don't know but I'll tell you one thing
you can say what you want about Hitler
I'm not a fan but my man sold tickets
yeah the Nazi Party was deep he was
selling out theaters Hitler the same
[ __ ] dude it's like John Wilkes Booth
dude yeah he [ __ ] that dude yo he
could act my packed the theater out man
yeah Leia bars but you know I mean he
killed you killed old old Abe yeah I
mean I guess it is kind of freeing to
realize like yeah I guess it was like
yeah we just have to try and make
something else happen of our own yeah
now do what you did well I'm telling you
man it's the best it's just like self
start and then you cannot take it away
it's exactly what Joe Rogan I mean I
know Joe Rogan did a lot of it the fear
factor and all that other stuff but I
mean that the things that people are
hanging their hats are now is things
they built not that somebody else built
not that somebody else is in control of
yeah like you got who care like well
even if Louise let's talk about let's
say louis c.k right if he started a
podcast tomorrow it would be the top
podcast
well probably be top podcast but it's
like he would monetize it instantly and
still be able to make you can't tell
he can't do a podcast right he could
tell me can't be on FX anymore you could
tell him you know what I mean he's not
doing these commercials theaters could
close their doors but you can't the
[ __ ] people yeah if he speaks to the
people man it's like nah you can't
people decide absolutely and then you
could be like hey listen if you want to
salute Lucy Kate podcast it's a dollar a
month trust me there's thousands
hundreds of thousands of people that
would do that just to hear it just yeah
just because they're fans of if it's
working I'm not advocating for him I'm
just using him as an example it's like
if really in 2019 like you can't be
stopped
you know if you put your mind and your
will to it and you want to say this is
what I want to do then you got to just
go do it because there's no excuses
anymore
yeah that's what I Roland said and we
were just talking with us with Kevin
Ealing the other day but yeah that's
what Donna Rowland said he said for
black people white for anybody you know
there's just there's no excuses you know
yeah he said that he felt like once
Barack Obama was president that like you
can't be a black person anymore and say
like oh I don't have this opportunity or
right I still think there should be more
opportunities for Latinos though in
America yeah like how do you don't have
it a lot t no on yeah I'm the [ __ ]
the Los Angeles Lakers I know well you
know what your offense is of your
audience of your fans or Latino I know
well the honesty [ __ ] Hector out
there there's a nine point no [ __ ]
Dickies dog yeah you know converse [ __ ]
it only gets to shoot nine point or
cigarettes in his ears yo but that [ __ ]
would be beautiful I mean Latinos I mean
they're gonna be the majority I believe
they're gonna be the the majority for
the population in our country it's very
soon I think in the next few years so
yeah they certainly need to be more
representative yeah but I think you know
everybody's like oh you got to have this
person you gotta have that person it's
like we got a breakdown Society it's
like let's talk numbers here majority of
our society is this race or that
majority of our society is you know this
sexual orientation and this religion so
it's like when you talk about television
specifically that's what it's geared
towards it's like yes you know you have
to have everybody represented but you
don't understand there's different
percentages of people I think here's the
thing here here's how I feel
everybody everybody you need to you need
to treat every single person fairly and
with respect anybody
comes into my life I treat them fairly
with respect I don't care what your
organization is racially or whatever but
when when we go along with this
narrative we're all created equal
it's not true it's not it's just not a
true thing it's something that is being
pushed that's a [ __ ] lie that I think
it's unfortunate for like my daughter
I'm gonna be honest with her I'd be like
listen we're not equal okay there's not
there's there's and that doesn't mean
you know you treat anyone any
differently than anybody else you love
and respect everyone yeah and you'd be
friends with everyone but to think that
you have the same opportunities as uh
it's it's it's a lie and on America it's
a lie
I don't want to bro like when I look at
like you know like you don't really want
it like in the end like it's like you
know like in the past year I've had
opportunity to be like you know to kind
of just be in a different space you know
like even a year and a half ago it's a
yeah it's definitely different like
going and having people come out to the
show but it's like I wouldn't have
changed you know I don't think I really
would have changed anything more I think
about it's like the best like that chip
on your shoulder was really was the most
enjoyable part of my life absolutely I
mean I don't know that you know the joys
of having a child or having that sort of
thing yeah but like just have enough
having a like Joe Rogan's was talking
about they had Universal income and
where everybody would get a flat amount
and so that their basic needs were met
hmm so then after that if everybody's
basic needs were met then they could
focus more on their well-being
Rayo front and advancement and stuff
like that
you pull that up a universal basic
income that's that's a dope thing to
think about right but what is this from
you saying he did this no it's just been
something this has been kind of
discussed mean there's I don't know if
it'd be a way to really fund it someone
like a socialist kind of a socialist
idea but then I was thinking about it
more I was thinking about it last night
I was like but would where would people
would there be as much incentive you
know like you you don't have a comeback
story then you don't have Rudy Ruettiger
yeah you know no listen man I think like
America the reason why America everybody
wants to come here and it's still the
number one country in the world is
because it's capitalists it's a
capitalist society so it's like yeah you
have to be you have to be unbelievably
good in this country to get ahead and
there's positives in that I think
but all you know the catch-22 is with
capitalist society comes greed I mean
like lawyer yeah you know doctors in
England don't need
you know I mean like a like a national
healthcare setting like a doctor still
great job but they're making $150,000 a
year doctors here are multi
multi-millionaire so that's going to
change a person and that's gonna the
evil parts of a person's brain are gonna
its it the ego you reckon the ego
unchecked so it's inevitable but I think
it's hard to say well let's take that
away cuz that's what makes AMERICA
AMERICA right you can make it here you
can make it anywhere and the only way
that the only way that that's saying
remains true is by having capitalism be
the thing that's you know governing us
and I think greed is gonna become I just
have this thing that greed this thought
that greed is gonna become like the bad
thing right right yeah because it is so
like at a certain point it's just dirty
you know point it's like what are you
doing like when you raise kids that have
no idea that have never waited a table
or never many Busboys or never had an
experience of like you know being assert
you know like you know having to do
anything for themselves it just I don't
know you don't get the most out of life
that way either like oh dude the best
parts of my life where I've really been
the shittiest court dude every time I
think about comedy
you know when I'm thinking when I'm like
reminiscing about [ __ ] it's always those
first two three years when you're like
really grinding out to an open mics
meeting people seen everything for the
first time I fantasize and romanticized
that part of my career cuz I'm like oh
[ __ ] like it was a bond there now it's
like sometimes you know you in a city
alone you're on state you doing [ __ ]
alone like you know you see your friends
popping off but it's from afar it's like
back in the day it's like hey if
somebody just got passed at a comedy
club they would throw a celebration yeah
it's it's you know but I think what
happened what's good about my daughter
is things have flipped now in the sense
that my daughter's number one my career
is number two I still give my whole I
give a lot of energy to my career and I
want you know I'm out here right now to
do things for my career so I you know
they're the only times I step away from
my daughter is if it's worth it either
financially if it's gonna push the ball
ahead in my career because that enhances
her life but I'm not you know some some
of my peers I'll notice like they have
children you know they're like ah man I
gotta go on the month I gotta go on the
road for a month it's just a job it's
like no it's not you [ __ ] idiot you
don't have to do that you're doing that
because you know you you're putting your
career
first and what happened was when I put
my career second number one my career is
better than it's ever been and it's
going up there's everything's going up
so I didn't lose any steam because I
still do my work you know I still I
still work at it but it kind of made me
realize like yeah the ugly parts of our
career like the you know the like the
loneliness of it or like you know the
greed or like do I really need to go
after everyone on social media do I need
to post this thing just to get a chance
to go viral like how much of myself do I
want to sell right do I want to go out
in the middle of the street and pull my
dick out to go viral
do I want to do that right and when I
put my career second it was the answer
was no because the truth is yeah I want
to sell out I don't need to sell it
arenas but I'd like to sell out theaters
yeah you know I don't I don't I I'm not
gonna I'm not one of those guys like
I'll do anything to make it that's not
true yeah I'll do anything to make out
that that I see sometimes like yeah I
don't know I've worried that I'm just
not gonna write that I'm gonna run out
of good ideas if I don't be a good
person that's like my thing well I think
it's caught I think yeah well that's
just positive and I believe a lot in
energy now you know ever since I ever
since I had my kid like loved the energy
like love is an energy and it's and it's
and it's real and palpable and I feel
with my daughter like mail us son do we
need somebody angels me I'm again I'll
get whatever probably that remote dude
we're missing some no I do not
Wow look I hate to interrupt Chris
shamelessly plugging his podcast a
million times but I have to let you know
that this past weekend is brought to you
by skill share skill share is an online
learning community for creators with
more than 25,000 classes and design
business and more you'll discover
countless ways to fuel your Crocs
curiosity creativity and career you can
take classes in social media marketing
mobile photography creative writing even
illustration think of something you
always wanted to be able to do now you
don't have to go to a four-year college
to do it you can learn it and start a
new side business develop a new side
skill it's all right there at skill
share it's there to keep you learning
thriving and reaching your new goals
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for our this past
week
listeners we are the type of people here
at this past weekend that continue to
evolve so you can get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free you can
learn anything and everything to sign up
go to Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare dot-com slash th
EO vo n to start your two months now
that's Skillshare comm slash Theo von
onward and now back to myself and mr.
Chris what's a [ __ ] home fries are we
talking about don't wreck fost potatoes
what are we talking about today what's
in the news today Nick let's see this
happened a little while ago but right
it's kind of relates to this this
podcast our man Chris Hanson and
actually more news as we record this
just broke he's being evicted from his
apartment Wow yeah what was he doing
cash in blank checks yeah he got in
trouble he he bought some merch from a
vendor Odom thirteen thousand dollars
tried to write out two checks to him to
pay him back kept begging for more time
those checks bounced so the guy called
the cops and there's his mug shot and
now it's a crime if one of your checks
bounces like if I wrote a check that
bounced that's a crime
yeah you should call your daughter's
school right now yeah because I've had a
couple of those puppies bounce it always
bounced I remember they would come back
NSF insufficient funds
yeah and I'll say this man Chris hands
was on here on the show yeah really and
[ __ ] dull and it was cool it was cool
yeah a great episode it was a fun
episode it was interesting you seem like
a good dude right warm dude he did seem
like a warm dude I mean he probably
still is it this doesn't make him a bad
dude no this doesn't make him a bad dude
yeah but he a pattern of behavior a
pattern of behavior and so he had a you
know he had an experience at a hotel we
know we put him up for a night in a
hotel and flew him out here right right
so and that's the only guest that we've
done it for right big Chris Hansen fan
of course I wanted him to you know I
just wanted to be able to sit
with them and Chatham and I don't even
think I did that good of an interview
but I think that it was uh you know I
learned as we learned as we go and but
then he like ran up extra nights at like
extra stuff at the hotel like and tried
to keep it on to our tab even though it
was oh like what like dinners and drinks
and [ __ ] like that
we agreed to only one night he tried to
do three say didn't have his credit card
when he left that when he left the hotel
yeah
huge room service bills so this isn't
shocking to you is what you guys are
saying cuz it was shocking to me but I
thought it was a misunderstanding when
it happened at the hotel but then you
see this init pattern yeah he's like a
antihero he's like catching predators
but he's a klepto behind the scenes yeah
this feels like it's got gambling
written all over it
spa treatments I don't know if it's a
gambling I think no in the sense that
you get guys who are compulsive gamblers
and gamble their funds away Duke gotta
do [ __ ] like this it's always I need
more time and even more time as soon as
you said the key said I need more time
that's gambling that feels like he's a
gambler Oh cuz it's time cuz I've if I
get this next bet then yeah it feels
like he's that's what it feels like but
I could be wrong well yeah well the
thing makes me think it just kind of I
don't know the first thing I thought was
man I wouldn't do this to somebody I
wouldn't you know have an extra $1,500
with the hotel bill you know man
yeah right for a couple of night to the
hotel ya know and not and try to be and
you know like he never pays you guys
back girl we got no we got literally the
according to the girl that helps us you
know arrange some of this she said like
that he was walking out of the hotel and
she was on the phone with the guy with
the front desk and the lady was
literally saying mr. handsome mr. Hanson
to have him put down his card his car so
he had to yeah yeah I had to so Wow
but I don't and the crazy thing is that
he didn't seem like if I to try to call
him or try to reach him like he wouldn't
have you know kind of tried to answer
like he wouldn't have answered the phone
it seemed like he would have answered
the phone he would have communicated
yeah but so yeah just kind of hurt my
feelings a little cuz it was like oh I
wouldn't do that to somebody you know so
if you had a bit of a sour taste in your
mouth for Hanson after that
spirits before this [ __ ] happened yes
interesting that's a very little bit and
he even text me today I didn't text him
back but this when he on yeah you don't
text people back you make people feel
bad man I to text out to you well can't
wait to see you playboy I'm in LA miss
you love you and you just wrote back
I'll be at the studio in 15 minutes yeah
I mean I was running late for that was
I'm gonna text him three days ago
enough of attraction between us I don't
want you getting any wrong but the thing
was it was like what but why would you
it must be some sort of a it felt like
an addiction that he holds because yeah
compulsion that's compulsion yeah thanks
new yeah yeah that's what I think oh
yeah what is he like is it to span like
I wonder what that is you know to the
need to live at a certain young cuz we
put them up it you know I think was a
four-season somewhere nice nice yeah so
it was yeah them it is probably an
adrenaline rush I bet you it's connected
to adrenaline man yeah are living a
that's the thing that's scary about
popularity and about their ego is it
warps you man it's it's almost like
people who get extremely famous it
becomes like that's a mental health
issue yeah being a big celebrity is a
mental health issue that people like
it's almost like quarterbacks you know
got to take that those tests you know
NFL you know NBA rookie camps they have
to go mandatory two-week training
mandatory about how their life's gonna
change that should be with celebrities
you become an a-lister yeah deadline
says you're an a-list or a variety
whatever you got to take a [ __ ] tour
just [ __ ] you got to take a course
bro the Wunderlich the Wonderlic sorry I
was let's say the one who loves I'm a
[ __ ] dumb piece of [ __ ] now you're an
okay guy I appreciate it brother of all
let me watch this bag I look so you know
what do you think alright still look fat
well the jacket definitely looks like
something that a trans worker wear yeah
or somebody operates transit you know
truck get bus drivers like a transgender
chapter oh no it stepped like a sexy bus
driver [ __ ] yeah something something
that a bus driver got your wife or or
husband that's yeah my rate is bike you
know yeah watch hundred percent yeah
yeah man I [ __ ] I just fake leather -
yeah yeah you got that rare body time I
got it I'm built like a kind of stove
wagon you
oh yeah I got I got that rare I'm a
letdown for women man oh you yeah cuz
when I take my shirt off it's a mess but
you go to the gym all the time I do but
I just you know I mean I just got
flubber so there's nothing I could do
you know I told you I told you a guy
told me I'd leading-man face best friend
body really awesome casting director
said you got leading their face best
friend body that's [ __ ] up thing to
say but it was hilarious yeah I tweeted
it I guess you got those blue eyes or do
you only look like a handsome guy who
kind of got up yeah like when you like
some elevator doors kind of smashed yeah
yeah well yeah the blue eyes or a
get-out-of-jail-free card yeah well I
think women feel like I could protect
them cuz I'm a bigger dude and whatever
but I feel like you know I noticed like
the pattern it's like the first month
women are really into me and then it
slowly starts to be like oh this guy
wasn't what I thought he was oh wow you
know so but it's all good
do you really notice that pattern I
noticed that pattern like girls are
usually in they're really in the first
few weeks and then they're really out
you know after that cousin you know I
you know biting my nails
eating my boogers you know like a
Dueling [ __ ] like you know like you know
being too open with them like hey I
slept in the bed with my mom so I was 15
you know be having anxiety being scared
of the dark not being able to fix [ __ ]
you know having one titty like way
bigger than the other you know [ __ ] like
that you know yeah for yeah you know
like that's the real me you know I'll
bite my toenails yeah don't be don't be
the real you dude for other yeah you
know say the real you for you yeah yeah
I think but it's so true if we were all
ourselves like you know if people really
knew about all yeah my try to share as
much as I can before you know it
sometimes it's like but if people really
knew like you know some of our behaviors
I think now that finishing thing I think
it's okay if people know your fears yeah
because that's something can really
relate to right but some behaviors yeah
make people really sketchy yeah yeah
like you know that and and like I met a
girl once I'm sorry to interrupt you but
she had I don't forget this and I will
forget she had you know and we dated for
a while and she would wear the same
panties right and sometimes she would
wear them backwards I'm one time they
had like a little kind of Duty kind of
touch interesting front did she have
fumes I don't know what that is but like
you know did the bad smell
oh I don't know I don't remember but
that's a big thing if a girl's fumes or
not oh I don't know yeah she this girl
does have switched her underwear around
you know but that but that may give off
some fumes yeah well when I see them
switched immediately yeah first of all
that is straight-up how they make
pinkeye okay that is not where it's made
paint guy the other day was [ __ ] wild
I think I my eye yes from farting on my
phone wet right I feel yo my fans call
me Chrissy well farts link as my [ __ ]
sound like they're in a well underwater
ass crack yeah I got a deep deep deep
[ __ ] man
that's what it is yeah yeah I had to get
a colonoscopy oh wow yeah the doctor
because he ought to tell him like I
played some audio on my farts and I sent
him to pick some pictures on my shits
and the office and he was like we need
to take a look and when they went in
there he said I like a look he said it's
all good so Harry Nasser was it that
Larry Nasser Larry Nance said we got to
take he said we got to take a look and
then he told me he said everything's
fine but he said you know in clinical
terms said I have a very deep deep
rectum well I said that's what's causing
the sounds of the farts pretty cool
rectum damn near killed Marley
um did he say that I reckon denry killed
him sounds familiar
Nick's his sister does colonoscopies oh
she's a GI doctor I didn't know she's
never on a freelance bro oh wow a
squeeze colonics Oh colonics yeah
cleaned your whole [ __ ] out you can
pretty much just come off the street
yeah yeah I mean basically the van will
pull up yeah you know you ever done one
of those you ever got you should cleaned
out like that no dude I'll let God do
what he needs to do inside of my body
yeah I am well I'm living Biblica living
technically I'm living bit what a piece
of [ __ ] um do we have some questions
that came in for christening when was
the last time you cried
like sobbing I really cried first of all
that guy looks like a sexy member of
Isis handsome handsome terrorist that
[ __ ] guy yeah cry yeah yeah just a
[ __ ] hot just modeled for a jihad
yeah like it's nervous wanted to like to
take you on like a weekend adventure
yeah
host you the host yeah the last time I
cried the last time I cried was actually
about five four days ago I cried because
I was I was I was uh talking to my kids
mom about uh about my daughter and just
thought we were just having a
conversation and I was just telling her
like I was just saying I just got
emotional I was just thanking her for
giving me Delilah oh well and I just
started to get like real I just start to
cry and she was like you know she kicked
me out but it's what it is
you know we're not together any powerful
yeah but I start to cry Wow
well you guys have another kid you think
you and her if I'm good is this how wild
I am and just how I feel if I'm gonna
have another child I prefer to be with
her I don't want my daughter to have
different moms you know I want my
daughter sibling to have a different mom
yeah so it's like I'd rather if I'm
gonna even though even though we're not
together you know she's she's not
interested in that she just want any
more kids but I up and I if I was gonna
have another kid I prefer to be with her
like let's do it this way even if we're
not together not saying we're getting
back together it's like this you know I
mean know that she's not in she's not
interested in it what's so huge because
it's like you know and it's a sweet it's
a sweet thing maybe I can imagine that
you know like just you know feeling like
wow I have this gift and even though
it's my daughter like I wouldn't have it
even with this person I may not even
always get along with perfectly yeah but
I wouldn't have it I would not have it
and she harbored her life and she's like
the mom is the most important so
sometimes you just got to be thankful
even though like we go through our own
[ __ ] romantically or we did yeah she
just needs to be thanked yeah I know for
because the Delilah changed my whole
life yeah my dad used to say what did
would he say to us he would say oh you
got to always love your mother that's
what he said yeah I always loved your
mother cuz yeah I think no matter
sometimes even what our moms do to us or
they don't do to us or provider don't
they the simple fact that they went
through all that is party you already
severe pretty severe because a woman
even like you know women you know get a
little bit they they really a lot of
their aging happens when they have a
child sure yeah the child takes and
that's why it's like children burglars
Roach burglars and that's why like you
know that's why I say love is is
powerful and I think can be measured
because it's like the kid the you know
what it does to a woman's body and how
much it changes their life the only way
that you don't remove it from your life
because you could all you could do is
not feed it or smother and it's gone
yeah but the only reason like you know
like a bug you know you have no attached
she's [ __ ] it but a bugs a living thing
like the child's a living thing but it's
like the cha there's like love love is
the energy that keeps that keeps keeps
it together
thankee and keeps keeps your child alive
in the beginning you know of course it's
nurturing and food and all that but it's
really love if you don't have love if
you didn't love it you'll just walk away
from it again the child can do nothing
so it's all love that's probably
happened sometimes - oh absolutely hear
about all the time people leaving their
babies out on doorsteps out in the cold
whatever they do ya know Duncan Don it
stunk doughnuts yeah I'm [ __ ] dog but
I like that I'm wonderfully you know I
thought about this a couple years ago if
they would have an app that would you
could find someone you wanted to start a
family with yeah it was just on that
like you know I want to meet somebody to
have a kid not about the love it's not
really about our connection yeah but to
see like you know how do we live it
close enough how would we you know with
this person be a loving enough person to
have a child with it just seems like a
safer place paper planes yeah I mean I
guess in some ways you know I mean
you're not sharing it with the person
but like you donate I've donated my
sperm and I was chose not I don't see I
don't want to be notified but like
somebody's pretty you know they serious
bro yeah and the doctor you do and bro
they the doctors told me in there they
said look they said you know you could I
get a doctorate degree they're like you
got a doctoral degree they're like so
your sperm will be women are gonna take
the sperm was the level of education
children out there follow probably but I
told them like I don't want to be
notified that's why they give that glue
bro no but but my point is is like what
you just said it's like when you donate
your sperm like women are out there that
are like you know maybe they're lesbian
couple or maybe they just don't want a
man in their life but they want to
procreate so that's kind of what they do
that they she looked at my profile if
someone did put they had a picture to
they have everything
whatever headshot did you give them um
was it haizen or what was it now I took
a picture in the office dude I would
only donate a little bit of sperm to him
how much do you give them I gave them
one load man I shot it out what a cheap
date dude they give you porn um what I
get maybe 125 on city
yeah cash money play cares money cuz
[Laughter]
Applebee's in Times Square did you
really
your alpha bees in Times Square's they
Jack the [ __ ] price up is [ __ ] if
you're ever in New York City do not go
to Applebee's in Times Square something
that costs $30 for a whole meal in the
outer boroughs will cost $30 a burger in
a valise in Times Square they really
there's a really piece of [ __ ] move that
they do as a corporation I could see
that yeah I'm not you know I'm gonna go
there this year I think New York would
you do Caroline's if you could do like
some good shows there or would you do
awesome yeah or no like a theater Oh
like me personally yeah well I headline
usually I do Gotham I've been headlining
gosh yeah Benny got them before but if I
could if I could sell enough tickets I
would do a theater yeah I'm sure I do a
theater yeah what's Caroline's like
compared room wise to Gotham I believe
Caroline's maybe could see a few more
people I believe and but but but
audience wise like you can have a time
square audience so you have a lot of
people there who know you but also a lot
of people who are just turret tourists
coming in where Gotham comedy club is
located on 23rd Street and 7th that's a
part of Manhattan that's not really
touristy right it's people that live
there you can have the neighborhood come
out so it's up to you what you want now
what about this though do you is
Caroline's how do you like performing
them which stage is better I haven't
been on Carol personally I like them
both but personally I feel comfortable
at Gotham just because I and the LAT let
you know the last couple years I've been
performing there a lot more than
Caroline's but I don't think you can go
wrong either way Caroline's is awesome -
I mean it's Caroline's is a they're both
iconic New York clubs and the only
places you can go to headline in New
York yeah I never been to Caroline's as
well you ever you've been inside at a
different experience nope it's like
right in Times Square it's [ __ ] huge
is it you know you go down these stairs
and whole [ __ ] opens up and the it's
mafia ran so it's kind of old-school
wide like Gotham or is it deeper is it
what's it like it's deeper than Gotham
for sure deeper than Gotham Gotham is
wide Caroline's is deep okay yeah just
thinking about that yeah yeah all right
I don't know about that Chris Hansen
thing I don't push it
maybe I should I'm officer I don't I
don't need to reach out to him and you
think I detected what he texted you he
just texted I don't think I don't think
it's it's not on you anymore
and you know I mean one did he text you
he's probably asking for money months
ago he was asking for looking for a
months ago not have been great though if
he was as long as as long as your check
cleared from him we had a question he
was pay he was gonna push the show and
stuff like that he didn't take me like
this week oh I think he did he ever push
the show out did he do it no he didn't
uh-huh we had a question that came in
the last hour for Chris so I haven't
even heard it
okay let's fire Lynn hey Theo hey Chris
this is Landon from Kansas City Missouri
and I was calling in about a question
for Chris but uh first I just wanted to
start by saying that I seen Theo on your
little show there Chris and you making
fun of the rat Kings hair you better
leave it alone you better leave him
alone
all right guys listen I just want to say
that you look Dutch and you look like an
aerodynamic Dutch person at that you
sure did all right yeah for you on
another note I just wanted to know how
old were you when you got into comedy
and what what attracted you to comedy
thank you first of all how I kid that's
one of your face just [ __ ] menace
Yeah right there what do you guys
probably your son do you know somebody
needs to [ __ ] start pumping ritalin
through that dudes air conditioner vents
he needs to calm the [ __ ] down it looks
just like your mom know that kid look at
his nose man he's got he's got lump the
[ __ ] up bro it's what happens when
you're you know when you don't know who
your dad is do you up a lot I like this
kid though he's a good kid I like this
this is my kind of kid I started comedy
when I was 25 years old it's the age I
started and then I was dude still doing
physical therapy
I'm sorry 24 I was still doing physical
therapy until I was about 28 and then I
started doing professionally since 28 28
years old yeah um I was trying to think
what else how old are you 30 38 38
yeah I'm 34 we run same age bro yeah do
you ever think about leaning into the
doctorate thing and being like a some
type of funny like a dr. Drew Todd can
oh we're like a doctor eyes like you're
like you got more qualifications than
that guy yeah yeah I mean you know yeah
I could see you having some hilarious
physical therapy videos online yeah
I should actually do it yet for my
career I should do that [ __ ] [ __ ] for
real that's what that oh that's my next
show that's my next idea line oh yeah
yeah producer your producer yeah getting
straighten straighten straightened out
yeah yeah yeah right yeah I you know
what I'm gonna start looking for kids
that look like you and [ __ ] where do
they mail the spun to what give me a
little bit more on the sperm before you
go off on this guys crotch shot even any
good you know I just went out you know i
splooged into the tube
what is it like in there they got a to
do you get different tubes you have two
options man you could either get your
prostate pushed on like a nurse so
coming to professor doing you just
splooge it out it's just like you're
lying I swear to God like it's like a
technique that these these nurses are
just good at just get the splooge on if
you don't wanna marrow it's rough I've
ever heard it dude somebody pushing and
what you gotta ask buttoning your ass
yeah oh and then the other one is they
got you go into this room and they got
um they got uh like nudie mags and all
that and then they give you the Wi-Fi
and my place had the Wi-Fi and you could
uh you know um jerk off or not yeah no
problem [ __ ] is it like a house or is it
a doctor
there was a doctor's office so it was
like just like you know you know secure
humming in a place like that I would
come at somebody's house if it were like
a DEET you know like yeah give your own
room or something I'm not gonna just in
a doctor and what you just let him walk
out of the room yeah I just get like
it's a few pain in a cup man I just came
home my glue yeah doesn't that feel
crazy you know wild if well the reason
why it all started is because when I got
my kids mom got pregnant you know she
had taken like a plan B after and I got
another girl pregnant like four years
before that so it was like this and she
was on birth control so it was like some
weird [ __ ] and the doctor the ob/gyn was
like you know you should get your sperm
checked like that's that's not normal so
I went got my sperm checked and I
donated it and so they had it and then
when I donated it they called me into
the office like three days later and
then we say good bat they had a good
back well they said to me it's like
there was three doctors that came in and
they said listen before they open up
they said where were you born
and I said Queen st. John's Hospital
Queens New York they said are you sure I
said 100% and they're like well like you
verify it can you verify with your mom
or dad and I said yeah but I thought you
was somebody else I'll call my mom and I
was like where was I born she said st.
John's Hospital Queens New York and I
said are you sure you're not lying to me
like I wasn't adopted she's like no you
I swear to god you weren't adopted so I
said what's going on start to get
nervous and he said well I have three
times the amount of sperm in every load
I mean you know he was I forgot what
technically I'm reap who is a guy know
he says his name he's a time he was a
time Chris Hanson yeah and so so so he
told me I have three times even sperm so
he asked me if I was born in how do they
know for how much it weighed like in
they did well this microscope but they
at least the only time they've ever seen
that like abnormality and mutation of
the sperm is as a child who's been born
near a nuclear reactor no they thought
maybe I was born in Russia near
Chernobyl and then they thought that
maybe I had a tumor on something but
what they found out was is that I have
an overactive CalPERS gland it's called
CalPERS Bennett's like what makes your
sperm and so my thing is is I make a lot
of sperm you get that hot cap I saw I
got a hot caliper so I can get a girl
pregnant the doctor exciting to me they
said you're the guy if a girl's looking
to conceive a child she wants a guy like
you but if you're looking at like just
one-night stands and have sex all night
you're not the guy cuz when I shoot it
out it takes a long time for my CalPERS
gland to refuel that my jizz and as I've
got also fielder exactly and as I've
definitely it's it's this is nestled
fielder's but it's a little slow yeah so
as I've gotten older it's been taken it
takes longer and longer so after I a
bust a nut no matter what it takes a few
days for me to catch an erection again
so but if I want to have children I can
get girls pregnant instantly you know
it's going to happen
Wow it's all a very high chance so
you're kind of yeah you should do tour
India or something yeah you can freakin
stop hanging out right or just I mean
for a hunter you might as well go
door-to-door to at least know what's
going on and get some of the joy out of
it yeah instead of throwing a whole bat
just some do for $125 on fish scale you
don't think Medicare Annette
yeah and he got like in New York that's
like dude you're looking at 35 you're
gonna 90 bucks yeah but I didn't get
[ __ ] and these just drive over there I
know I took the train yeah yeah you know
it was this ostrich who the [ __ ] takes a
train to [ __ ] jerk off for 90 bucks
yo man Louie CK yeah he does it on the
train yeah what is it what did his
clothes
louis ck's closer when he does another
special yeah he's just like hey I just
want to let everybody know in here that
I'm in about to jerk off right and you
can stay if you want
yeah and then the lights just go off I
wouldn't he just honestly loved it
I would love it man that'd be dope
that'd be tackling the [ __ ] head-on and
it's called you can stay if you want you
could say if you want that's what the
special is called yeah would you watch
it I would 100% watch it what are you
watching i like lucy case comedy yeah
dude he's one of the greatest of all
time when you watch it in a one of those
interactive theaters like 4d hundred
percent with those oculus virtual
reality caucus and just get [ __ ]
splooged on 100% oh that's not particle
it's just you it like be able to hear it
better you might fall me looking at
nibble on some [ __ ] how long have you
eaten know you gotta go street the
airport yeah i know [ __ ] go I would
have I would have loved to hang you say
that car right there Darryl Strawberry
you weren't there that day when I ran
into Darryl high on cocaine were you
know but he was coked out of his [ __ ]
mind
oh you were coked out of your mind yeah
yeah I saw the pictures of it yeah let's
talk about Opie real quick you know
let's do it when was the last time that
you went cuz the show I was out of town
than the show to shut down the last time
I went on Opie and Sirius was one of the
last time one of his last episode
whaling last yeah cuz we're pretty cool
but I've done his podcast he has a
podcast now I do I like Opie I'm
grateful he's give me great
opportunities I mean he's just had a you
know he had a kind of a sordid ending
over there so yeah it was kind of abrupt
and wacked but I still do Jim and Sam -
it's all love over there it's like for
the most part you know they may have
their issues but for the comedian's like
they've kept us out of it and like we
can we're free to roam on both dude
shows yeah so it's pretty pretty awesome
you know what that is pretty cool
actually uh that both yeah like yeah
like Jim and Opie seem to like not get
along yeah but that yet they never
seemed like oh you were on that guy's
thing now they don't feel that way not a
heady nowaday ain't petty they're not
petty at least not for me yeah so it's
dope that's same man do you miss the
show I do I do because I feel like you
know it was fun we were going there in
the mornings or afternoons and you know
the vibe was dope you know like we go on
YouTube [ __ ] around meet all kinds of
people and now it's like you know it's a
little different in New York like you
know it's like you guys feel like you
have like this you know podcasting
networks and you're
fighter and the kid is right across all
it's not like they in New York like
people are doing podcast in their in
their apartments all right in the studio
where it's just them they're sharing
office space so it's like Sirius XM was
dope and Opie shows dope because like
you would be in there doing somebody
else's show and then walk past opening
he call you in it was like this
open-door policy yeah that's kind of
gone now so oh I felt like I'd arrived
man when I got on that show um yeah it
was so nice to be able to just go in
there and it was yeah that's how I met
you yeah that's how mark Normand and I
even became buddies you know we grew up
in the you know in the same area there
were so many people I met in there I got
to talk to Danny McBride in there how I
was with you yeah have you ever met him
I met him one time after that it was
dope
it was really quick I just got a picture
with him in Montreal last year oh [ __ ] I
wasn't remembers that phone call
probably not it was probably the tenth
phone call he did that and I said
something stupid to like I was like sure
he's like yeah yeah oh dude and I didn't
know what to Sarah morning I was like
god I think I'm gonna say this and then
he's like how's the day everything going
good for you you know we're just taking
a picture just saying like small talk
and I was like yeah man a lot of ladies
up here you know good you have brought
my dick and he didn't say anything yeah
[Laughter]
said that and it was so uncomfortable
and right when I didn't get any reaction
while I was like I'm never gonna be in a
movie with him I'm never gonna see him
I'm never gonna get to donate sperm in
his area area dude the other day I was
that I was doing Doug loves movies Adam
ezb Franklin it was so fun Doug's the
[ __ ] man and I was doing a UCB
Franklin which is like you know they're
great fans over there but it's like you
know they're real PC and I just forgot
because New York you can just say [ __ ]
it's not as PC as it is out here
yes out there that I was like telling
some story about how like I was out of
play once and like my boys were like
look at this girl's ass and like I like
in New York it's like it gets a laugh
but they are they're like oh like it got
real long yeah when I started bomb and
you know cuz like I was just it was like
just objectifying women and you know New
York people even when we like just laugh
but out there they were like you [ __ ]
pig piece of [ __ ] like you're the
problem
yeah I was like oh boy it's crazy cuz as
you drive over to the part of town all
the billboards are objectifying women of
course Instagram it's all [ __ ]
that's the thing if it seemed nobody
cares it's all [ __ ] it's like as
soon if you're a person
that you're like spilling your agenda to
me I'm stay away from you cuz I'm like
you're hiding [ __ ] you're just hiding
[ __ ] well I just hope to be able to just
be in a good place in this I just want
to learn as I go you know and I just I
mean I get stressed out that's one thing
it's different and recently just been
more stressed it's just it why bro it's
just a lot going on you know it's
stressful you know and I've never had
anybody where I work together you know
Nick and I worked you know it's who
Nick's in here so like sometimes I don't
communicate well with him and then it's
like you know I'm stressed and then it's
like but you know what the only person I
talk to your next like pretty much my
girlfriend oh man yeah but you do I mean
you make up money now you're doing like
real [ __ ] you're doing what you want to
do whatever you want yeah
yeah so I don't know so I don't know
what it is sometimes it's like what's
making well just think about just just
just you know ask ten years ago Theo if
he would be stressed if you don't Theo
of ten years ago you're gonna have all
this I think he would be like oh my god
I'd be over the moon if you told me I
can have that I have no problems well
now you're here
yeah scenario you're just creating
problems you don't have any problems
yeah you've you've made it in many ways
yeah you should just take comfort in
that and just you know because there's a
lot of people that would do anything to
have what you have
so I think it's important for us to
check ourselves right every you know so
often every two three months whatever
you want to do calibrate it but you got
to check yourself and echo how would the
how would the older how would that
latest version of me feel about what
this new version has they probably be
happy about it
so let's take comfort in that yeah it's
new problems but it's all good problems
champagne problems [ __ ] that's a
good uh I don't know what dude I wanna
[ __ ] kiss you on the lips you wearing
underwear huh yeah I'm wearing my undies
do they were one of our sponsors but
Tommy John deserted us Tommy John no
that's all surgery no it's a good way to
like think about like the class and
think about now you know I don't feel in
your friend of just feel like yeah I
just want to be funny you know who you
are though that I want to be calm I want
to be yeah your fan
my point is like you're you your fans
are invested now your fans aren't going
anywhere you know what I mean yeah
they're not going anywhere so they [ __ ]
with you neither is me undies by the way
we're still part of me undies fan oh
really yeah we got some coming up same
boy pair double XL yes you can pull them
down and just common work
some people do you should do that at the
meet-and-greet after your show bus into
a car no that'll go viral I'm gonna
start doing on my podcast just coming on
the pod yeah
I haven't been on Toby's new show have
you been on it yes I've been on I'm
doing it next week this is a podcast you
know one of the podcasts we did we just
like walk around New York City so it's
kind of dope but now he's got a studio I
think it's Westwood one podcast studio
so and it's doing well I mean you know
people love Opie hope he's all good
brother I mean they've got an 8 bedroom
apartment on the Upper West Side
I mean Opie's dough is that real is it
yeah Oh Opie Opie crushed it yeah you
could say what you want about Opie I
mean he [ __ ] crushed it in this radio
game yeah make millions of dollars yeah
I'm not saying anything about it no no
I'm saying you know how fast are you no
I mean yeah yeah people get you know get
on everybody when it's like hey this
dude [ __ ] changed radio for a little
bit over here yeah you know if there was
no Howard Stern you might have been all
about Opie yeah I was trying to think of
some things that are really like
positives for him and I was thinking he
met Carl you know Ruis yeah yeah and
they love doing stuff to get absolutely
now Carl's divorced and lived in the
woods so it's like yeah it's you know
what I mean sometimes your [ __ ] just
spins out hey yo I love Carl man oh he
can cook y'all he just [ __ ] he does
cocaine off hot dogs I mean legit got
divorced and lived in a cabin in the
woods and he's like I'm killing it and I
believe him comes out with just sandals
and socks on we used to do that [ __ ]
brother it's called a Somalian wild wild
fire oh you do cocaine off a hot dog and
[ __ ] eat it yeah dude Somali wow it's
so hard to eat it after brother the last
thing you want your mouth after you've
had some coke is that [ __ ] hot dog no
[ __ ] hot yeah you know for some
fellows anyway yeah I've [ __ ] deep
doubt that [ __ ] right now well I'm not
gonna do that
Christa's stefano thanks for coming man
yeah this is cool
y'all got my special coming out size 38
waist Comedy Central writing yeah
brother rare size 38 waist bro Chrissy
[ __ ] hips I mean you were built like a
[ __ ] Rubik's Cube dude I'm like a
stepmom I got a stepmom ass you are mom
Gina I got that stepmother vibe yeah
yeah we're a pronoun me wear an apron
dude bro most coats are where they have
to cover my ass I'm always um I'm rockin
trench coats usually twelve months out
of the year
gotta cover that butt up look at the
wheelbase on that bad boy yo and then
check my podcast history hyenas history
I in is with you and Yanis Papas yeah
and your special is coming on the 18th
Friday January 18th so tomorrow there's
tomorrow babe oh [ __ ] when does it
should come out next week next week this
this actually is gonna come out February
seventh we had a bunch in the can but
what we'll put out on all your social
thing you'll put on social media and
also um you know that it came out
already but you could see how now family
central.com in the Comedy Central app
it's streaming right now my special size
38 ways to check out check it off yes SR
you ace I'm excited to check it out man
and thanks for coming dude thanks to him
you helped me think about stuff course
brother we out here
[Music]
little town for me to set that parking
brake can let myself
[Music]